we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p the
voicemail line this month is made
possible by our friends over at linguist
who want to help you take your language
learning to the next level I've been
using linguist myself to brush up on my
French in advance of very interesting
work project I have coming up in France
I love it because it uses AI to adjust
to your exact skill level I've taken
French before I don't want to sit there
wasting my time going over stuff I
already know and that's exactly what
linguist
prevents me from having to do please try
it out free no credit card needed Ling
viscom / Pakman Ling vist with a V comm
slash Pakman okay today's voicemail you
might remember the Kansas troll the
Kansas troll an extraordinarily racist
callers of the show he has face-planted
on our program he's face planted on sam
cedars program the majority report today
we got a call from the san antonio troll
okay the san antonio troll has been
missing for a while and the san antonio
troll does something very similar to the
kansas troll which is they call up and
they criticize me for things i've never
talked about i don't know if they're
hearing this stuff on other shows i
don't know if they're just trolling but
after i think it's been like a year or
longer without hearing from the san
antonio troll he resurfaces and slams me
brutally for something i've never even
spoken about on the show hey sack man
how's it going a quick question you
often bring up karl popper's intolerance
of intolerant will officially lead to
the downfall of the tolerant blah blah
blah doctors you're such an expert on
karl popper maybe you can answer this is
karl popper's solution to the intolerant
to debate the bad ideas or it's his
solution to ban anyone who isn't pro
democrat like you proposed that's all
pac-man just a quick question i black a
word salad aside i don't think i've ever
mentioned
all popper on this program I'm not an
expert in Karl Popper my exposure to
Karl Popper is mostly limited to I
believe a Nassim Nicholas Taleb writes
about popper in his book the Black Swan
and maybe Daniel Kahneman has written
about popper but I am no expert on
popper I would be shocked if his name
has even been mentioned more than in
passing once or twice on this program I
have no idea what you're talking about
must be some other show you're referring
to maybe you got your speed dial messed
up and you were meaning to call I don't
even know Sam cedar or Kyle kolinsky or
Genki ogre or somebody else but you got
to do better San Antonio troll to come
back to come out of the woodwork after a
year with that horrible nonsense
voicemail disappointing I would have
expected better from him we've got a
great bonus show for you today
although Isis may be out of territory
they still have a bunch of money and we
will talk about what impact that could
have we will also talk about the Supreme
Court looking again at partisan
redistricting and we have follow-up from
the Australian teen who egged an
Australian senator all of those stories
and more on today's bonus show get
access by becoming a member or a patron
and I will speak to you then